I wrote it I think I'm off so I had a
woman stay with this guy and it was so
good that I was like I'm a repeat
customer so I'll try to make it two
nights and so texting him and also Chios
texting him saying things like come over
LSU ble to blood I'll lick your toes
I'll be a prick for you even though I
like any of that stuff except for the
icing of the day I love and then I was
kind of drunk so I ended up passing out
before I had fallen asleep I had lit a
candle and like a night taken off my wig
and when I woke up I was curling my wig
like a baby and the candle is still
burning I mean this is so funny so I was
texting my friend like girl you'll never
guess what happened last night
I'm trying to get the wit of candle took
off my wig and passed out so then I had
sent and realized I sent it to him
loving I'll know and he responded with I
don't think he meant to send my screen I
look cool oh thanks fast I got it I did
mean to send it to you do you want to
come over I'll put my wig on OCD right
now and he said no pro tip if you're
holding your wigs no one's holding you
you